alex jones
is now
very very excited
[Music]
[Music]
that's true
[Music]
is
[Music]
that is
[Music]
[Music]
trump was doing this with his personal
toilet
toilets
and
10 times shows times
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
10 times
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements of bathrooms
mangoes my bags are mangoes
i love mangoes too
okay
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
wisconsin crowd identified with the
mangoes
personally affected the american people
don't want me to be healthy
healthy don't want me to be
[Music]
well welcome everybody what an evening
everything everything everything
happening today it is truly an
incredible situation
we have all sorts of breaking news so
much so that it just wasn't enough to
cover
stuff
on the the show today and the show
tomorrow
there's so much news breaking that in
order to get to everything we need extra
streams and this is it there are three
breaking stories right now
all of which point to
more and more criminality dumping in
on the trump crime family first and
foremost donald trump today claimed that
the fbi seized three passports of his
during the search warrant at mar-a-lago
last week
he said one of them was actually we
let's
let's just pull up the truth
where is my truth social
uh
here it is
donald trump making the following claim
and of course the claim is already being
called into question
uh you can never be okay here it is
wow in the raid by the fbi of mar-a-lago
they stole my three passports one
expired along with everything else
this is an assault on a political
opponent at a level never seen before in
our country
third world and we will ban
men and as you can see people
immediately suggesting trump actually
flee the country now if it is true
that donald trump's
passports have been taken
first question is why did he why does he
have two unexpired passports sometimes
you do see this among
um oh hold on a second we've already got
a wow
something about our recent streams are
really really really triggering people
to the point where we're having to ban
dozens of people at a time sometimes you
would have two unexpired passports
because of diplomatic reasons uh
sometimes if diplomats deal with for
example
iran and israel iran doesn't recognize
israel's existence so you have one
passport for when you go to israel but
then you have a different passport port
when you go to iran
so that iran doesn't see the stamp from
israel
when i went to israel instead of
stamping my passport they just gave me a
little card actually so that then it
wouldn't be permanently in if in case i
wanted to go to you know certain
countries okay so that'll be one thing
that's
why does he have two passports there are
some explanations for that
more importantly
if indeed donald trump had his passports
taken
it means that to some degree
the fbi has identified that he is a
potential flight risk and they've taken
the passport so that the president can't
leave the country
that's crazy if that's true and the
reason i keep saying if that's true you
will hear in a moment
um if indeed the fbi has determined we
don't leave town right the proverbial
don't leave town and they have seized
his passports
it is an historic moment and a historic
moment it's everything
because it means that a former president
cannot currently travel to anywhere uh
else
now
why do i say if it's true
we are already getting conflicting
information on this
nora o'donnell from where is she from
from cbs just tweeted this was moments
ago
according to a doj official the fbi is
not in possession
of trump's passports
trump had accused the fbi of stealing
his three passports during a search of
his home
we are also learning tonight that if any
items not contained in the warrant were
retrieved they will be returned
according to this
trump is lying
according to this
however there were also reports i just
saw
which say that the fbi now says they
will be returning trump's passports to
him
if the news is the fbi will return the
passports it means they did seize them
and is this a semantic issue where it's
the fbi is not in possession but
someone else is some intermediary we
don't really know we don't really know
but a major major element of news and i
believe that drudge still has it yeah
dredge still has passports seized
but it links to the daily mail
which is a site you can flush 10 to 15
times
uh not not a particularly reputable site
so that is first and foremost
absolutely incredible that's one bit of
news
second bit of news as cnn is currently
covering prosecutors have told rudy
giuliani he is indeed a target in the
georgia 2020 presidential election probe
so remember that when the fbi requests
your presence i'm sorry when prosecutors
request your presence not the fbi um
sometimes they will tell you you're not
a target we want to talk to you as a
witness and it's useful for people to
know it's useful for people's lawyers to
know etc rudy giuliani has now been told
he is indeed a target this means he is
suspected of criminality and rudy
giuliani may be charged now i also have
some giuliani
elements here
uh let's get to them a little bit later
okay so not a good day for rudy giuliani
and of course it's getting closer and
closer and closer to trump himself
in addition to this it's just the bad
news is is endless
it is now being reported
that alan weiselberg
the cfo of the trump organization this
is the top financial guy for trump's
business which is accused of all sorts
of financial wrongdoing including
maintaining two sets of books one which
inflates the value of trump's properties
when it's convenient to use them as
collateral another set of books which
minimizes the value of trump's
properties which is convenient when you
want to argue that your property taxes
are too damn high okay
alan weisselberg
is expected to
uh take a plea very soon however however
um
it is believed that he has not
turned on trump in any way he's not
cooperating in that sense
he
the reporting is that for his own
benefit he is determined he's going to
take a plea rather than go to trial
for remember this is all this is all
criminality
as cfo of the trump organization
but every report so far is he has not
turned on trump and it may not be
bringing prosecutors anywhere closer to
prosecuting donald trump himself but
again
crimes committed
for trump
much like our friend michael cohen
who has been on the show and whose show
i've been on
so just
bad news after bad news after bad news
for
donald trump and it is really an
incredible situation we we really have
never had anything like this before it
is accurate to say that we've also never
had a president do the things trump did
um
okay so let's now dig further in as we
do that let me make sure i'm keeping up
with thanking people who are supporting
our stream today thanks to blueberry
babe as well as 42 pounds green man and
rich bird nation which puts us at four
i also want to thank people signing up
on my website it is stunning what is
happening on the website and i want to
say thank you to juan
armendares for signing up at
jointpakman.com your new member number
five and also thanks to people gifting
memberships that includes jason
sickmeyer
denver mccarthy
and kevin combs putting us at eight we
have a goal here of 100 website members
and twitch subscribers today we have a
coupon code the coupon is indict and you
can use that on my website i will thank
every single one of you who uses the
code now i'll tell you there's an even
see even bigger secret code
the code is obama
and as you can see here
it's criminal
it's criminal what the code obama does
for you
so just keep that in mind and i will
thank absolutely everybody who uses any
of these coupon codes uh on the website
let's look at a few super chats before
we move on to some of the other video
clips related to today's stories adam
says spread more love eat more mangoes
in a beautiful 50 super chat thanks adam
jerry says democracy will not withstand
another trump election loss yeah i don't
know that democracy will withstand a
trump win
or a trump loss it seems either way
democracy is in peril
raymond says only trump can say you save
you long louv trump looks like we got a
trumpist in the audience
well welcome raymond i appreciate you uh
spending five british pounds
to uh
let me know about that beautiful message
that's extremely exciting thank you
i also want to say thank you to s prez
who just dumped in 50 gifted twitch
subscriptions
it is incredible
that we are at a level we've never been
before
in terms of twitch subscriptions as you
can see above me it says 22.75
thanks to those 50 were actually over
2300 we've never been at 2500 which is
incredible let's get into a bunch of
different things that i have for you
here uh first before we get back to
trump's passport being seized and
everything else we have going on today
bo hines is a republican gun nut who's
running for congress in north carolina
he thought that when people use the term
banana republic we are a banana republic
that they're talking about we've turned
into a banana republic store some of you
may be familiar that there are stores
called banana republic in the united
states it's a chain
uh size small
button-down shirts from banana republic
are a beautiful item that i will
sometimes wear now that's different than
a quote banana republic which often is
it's quite frankly a pejorative meant to
be
um sort of like a
it kind of means you're like a backwards
nation that your most advanced industry
is growing bananas okay it's a
pejorative bo hines didn't get that
and this video
saturday night live has to end
because you can't ridicule this it's a
self parody look at this you get the
congress
is it going to be real are we actually
going to be willing to defund irs fbi
things of that nature well i mean we
have to i mean we're at a point in our
country now we have a unregulated fourth
branch of government that's targeting
middle-class americans on a daily basis
i mean it's unbelievable what we're
saying you know a lot of people liking
the situation that's going on right now
is you know they say we're in a banana
republic i think that's an insult to
banana republics across the country i
mean at least wait a second what do you
mean banana republics across the country
manager banana republic unlike our
president knows where he is and why he's
there and what he's doing
oh boy
the manager of a banana republic store
oh god
oh dear god we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines
the country has really turned into the
gap guys
it's really turned into jc penny
this guy has a shot
okay this guy has a shot
more like banana republicans am i right
he'd like to speak to the manager of
banana republic to see if he can fix the
country
unbelievable
truly and genuinely unbelievable
it's
it's beyond belief
it's beyond belief other super chats
coming in can we get a flight risk
coupon code okay yeah i'll make a deal
with you guys all right
if we get to a hundred website members
on the basis of the reports that trump's
passports have been sheased
sorry seized i will make a flight risk
coupon code
and it will be like some kind of crazy
discount like maybe we'll even go to 70
or something like that
i want to know how he would even be able
to leave the country without being
recognized in the logistics of secret
service he he flies private so that's
how he would do it that there's a
there's an answer to that
now trump can't travel to s-hole
countries exactly
exactly
um okay
let's continue because we have uh
significantly more things to look at
here do we want to look at the andrew
yeah let's get back to the andrew yang
interview a little bit later um okay so
we looked at this
donald trump is
seemingly threatening to incite another
riot in the middle of everything that's
going on he's he's
sort of trying to hold leverage
by
saying that he
is going to do whatever he can to help
the country
but that the temperature has to be
brought down this is unbelievable look
at this former president trump said he
will quote do whatever he can to help
the country after the raid of his home
stressing that the temperature has to be
brought down
and that the american people are not
going to stand for another scam so he's
basically saying
if this goes forward
the people aren't going to stand for it
okay
the country is in a very dan you really
have to read between the lines here
the country is in a very dangerous
position
there is tremendous anger
much of it inspired by trump like i've
never seen before over all of the scams
which aren't scams but that's what trump
tells his followers and this new one
years of scams and witch hunts and now
this now listen look carefully
if there is anything we can do to help
i and my people would certainly be
willing to do that
there has never been a time like this
where law enforcement has been used to
break into the house of a former
president of the united states they
didn't break in
they had a search warrant and everything
everything that has ever happened at
some point happened for the first time
and trump goes on to say and there is
tremendous anger in the country at a
level that has never been seen before
trump told fox news his team has not yet
heard from the justice department
whether they will accept his offer for
help
i think they would want the same thing
i've never seen anything like this it's
a very dangerous time for our country
it's only dangerous because of trump's
sycophants being willing to do violence
okay trump's making it dangerous i will
do whatever i can to help the country
um
then they break into a president's house
sneak attack where it was totally no one
ever thought a thing like this would
happen
trump told fox news that fbi agents
break in and take whatever they want
trump said fbi agents told his team to
turn off the camera and no one can go
through the rooms
they could take anything they want put
anything they want in
trump went on to suggest the fbi could
have planted anything they wanted
now look at this
this is the key paragraph
people are so angry at what is taking
place whatever we can do to help because
the temperature has to be brought down
in the country
if it isn't
terrible things are going to happen
trump is saying
in his deranged trumpian way
if you don't back off justice department
people's anger
is going to cause terrible things to
happen which people
well his followers
meet normal people people like most
people in the audience
people like me people were not angry at
what happened
probable cause
uh
fbi director appointed by trump okay's
the search warrant
department of doj
a.g okays it
judge okays it
we're not mad
who is it that's so mad that might do
the terrible things
it's trump's followers
trump is subtly or not so subtly
threatening
to incite another january 6th and i have
to tell you
i'm worried it would be worse than
january 6th
because of the number of people
that absent any clue whatsoever what the
hell is going on
uh believe that there has been something
illegal in the search warrant
extraordinarily dangerous
and absolutely people in the audience
saying that this is stochastic terror
all right look at this headline
unprecedented number of threats
following mar-a-lago search they are
already threatening violence one guy
showed up at the capitol today
uh or yesterday drove into drove into
some barriers and ultimately did he
shoot himself or was he shot i don't
remember the details
cincinnati fbi field office
angry guy who was at the capitol on
january 6 showed up and shot it up
his people are dangerous
people are extraordinarily dangerous
before we continue
shot himself okay um let me continue let
me just make sure i'm thanking everybody
here p-funk apocalypse has gifted five
subscriptions on twitch and comer has
signed up for one
that's six putting us at 64. if we get
to a hundred we're we're launching a
flight risk coupon code which will be 70
off let's see how close we can get there
the following people have just signed up
emily weeks is a new member aj johnson
is two
barbara hostetler is three
roy smith is four
angel allen is five
david mccandless is number six
greg gregory mcdaniel is number seven
jess stumbaugh
is number eight josh buma is number nine
brandon cobb is number 10.
jennifer sherping is number 11.
stephanie king is number 12.
barry shepard is number 13
sam seitz is number fourteen
jennifer lolly is number fifteen
anthony barnes clark is number sixteen
lauren estell is 17 teddy reiner is 18
and kellan morse is number 19.
19 64 puts us at 83
but we have a few more gifts
stanley minarik has gifted a
subscription well we might actually get
there jason
sickmeyer has gifted one jason amos has
gifted one
that puts us at 86.
um jolt energy can betsu and tulmu as
well as herp z yikes
have also signed up via twitch
and there it is thanks to s prez gifting
30 more subscriptions
that puts us there all right let me
create this coupon code before we move
on i have to tell you i did not think
that would happen so quickly
uh the coupon code is going to be flight
risk and it is because it appears they
consider donald trump a flight risk at
this point if indeed his passports have
been seized although there are now
conflicting statements about the seizure
of donald trump's passports but let's
create this coupon code and see if
people like it
uh it'll be it'll be yeah it'll i'll
even do 71 off just to make it like
extra titillating to people
uh where is my coupon code creator here
coupons
this is just a brief interruption we're
getting we're getting right back to okay
new coupon code
coupon code is flight risk all one word
flight risk we will call it 71
off
and let's hit it
yet arguably the passport should have
been taken a long time ago i i don't
disagree with that all right
the coupon code is live it is flight
risk i'm not going to put it up there
just because if if you're not here and
hearing it right now you just don't get
it
okay you've got to be here and
understanding that we have just launched
the coupon code is flight risk it's 71
percent off
and it's absolutely titillating
absolutely titillating okay well uh
while we stand by for more here let's
look at a few other super chats the
former president is literally
threatening to incite his zealots to
open combat yes indeed
that's exactly what he's doing
david love the show want to comment on
today's podcast carrie lake people who
are overweight don't suffer from bds
i think you mean bde
yeah i mean listen this is like it's so
beneath american politics
but
it's also just like
i mean
i i i don't even know how to explain it
uh carrie lake said that she feels
feels maybe feels is the wrong word
that donald trump and ron desantis have
large penises
is gutsy
the guy has bigger
okay
this i'm sorry to turn this into a
cringe stream i really am wait let me
think about how i want to word this my
staff always says whatever you do do not
say balls
so i'm not going to say it
that guy
[Music]
has a backbone made of steel
[Applause]
i'll tell you what he's got i don't know
if you heard of this but he's got bde
anybody know what that means
ask your kids about it later
i call it big
desantis energy
right
he's got the same kind of bde that
president trump has
anyway so now i guess it's a republican
uh plank
to
talk about penis size i mean it's just
bizarre
it's completely and totally bizarre then
and they
supposedly this is now like a the
christian platform or something i i
really do despise her i really she's a
horrifying horrifying horrifying person
thanks to tri-kill eric for the twitch
prime subscription putting us at 121
nicholas patrick gifted five
subscriptions via youtube which i
appreciate
let's continue looking at other super
chats what are implications of a former
president being investigated this way
does this open the doors for an
investigation into other former
president we can't say for the only
implications are
maybe there will be some accountability
for donald trump
right now let's just leave it at that
bronx bjorn says when will the fake news
media call it what it is they are bad
hombres unamerican the enemy of the
people magga is hate
indeed it is
haven't seen the headlines yet but
assuming fox is running with trump calls
for calm how they do it daily with a
straight face is as incredible as it is
disgusting
i agree with you completely
trump being the one self-reporting all
this injustice shows how much he wants
people to riot for him and throw the
election indeed
richard york is from ocean view delaware
and was a registered democrat supreme
court incident okay
he's got some real big apple bags says
haley yeah that's basically what carrie
lake is saying
trump riots 2022 is this becoming a
yearly thing when will desantis announce
his run i think he's the republican
golden child he may be he may end up
that way
sure trump has bde
big dementia energy
wow
i love to whine and i whine and whine
and whine until i win donald trump but
sure sure bde all right let's look at a
couple other things because we have so
many other things to look at
uh
here is a clip from uh newsmax where
again there we now have another person
pushing this idea that the fbi search
warrant is the first step of the deep
state ultimately assassinating donald
trump we heard this from steve bannon we
heard it from bernie carrick and now
we're hearing it from rudy giuliani now
i still have not gotten an answer to
if the plan is eventually for the deep
state to assassinate donald trump
why do you need to serve a search
warrant first
just doesn't make any sense said
something before in third world
countries and banana republics they
arrest the
former uh
don't kill them
it's actually at banana republics j cruz
and expresses that they do it
donald trump should be in any fear of
the deepest of deep stations maybe
killing him
i do yeah
well i'm just putting him in jail in
many different ways i do i mean the
amount of hatred generated toward him
right
is the kind of hatred we worry about
that would set off a sick person i agree
i mean if there is anything to the fact
that right hatred can set off sick
people i agree there's no one where more
hatred has been generated by the
mainstream media who do they hate more
than donald trump they hate they display
it at uh emmy awards they display
everything uh
can you imagine
this the the
completely legal
search warrant
with a go-ahead from christopher wray
merrick garland and a judge is the start
of the assassination of donald trump are
these people stupid or just they [ __ ]
they're just morons
it simply doesn't make any sense
here is donald trump's attorney one of
the attorneys alina habba
saying that it would get really chaotic
if trump were to be criminally charged
what people are saying is it had to do
with jan 6 that had to do with a lot of
things at the end of the day i think
that would cause so much mayhem that
would be a monstrous mistake i also just
don't understand he was cooperating they
had been on premises prior he had had a
subpoena that they coordinated effort
with his team to come in they told us to
lock it up they locked it up so why why
did you need after two months to have
this insane raid you know it's it's it's
a sad thing for our country it just
doesn't make sense to me as an attorney
i can't make sense yes as an attorney
she can't make sense of it as an
individual she also can't make sense of
it um just about everything she said
there is is a lie
and we're going to be uh exploring it in
detail on tomorrow's show here's another
clip from this very same interview
talking about donald trump's deposition
with the um attorney general of uh hold
on is she d she d a or a g
of new york now i'm not remembering
um
she's the a.g of new york leticia james
and he took the fifth on every single
question
what was that like uh long yes
but they were so pleasant and we got
along with leticia and her team
fantastically which was quite surprising
i i wasn't it is surprising for trump to
get along with anyone that's true acting
to see miss james there but when she was
there i was actually pleasantly
surprised at the rhetoric between the
president and her and myself and the
team and they couldn't have been more
courteous we honestly it was the
strongest rhetoric anyone's ever seen
all got along the president at one point
went around the table and and uh shook
her hand were you surprised by that did
you was it gamesmanship on the part of
the attorney general or is there some
general
actual affection it was genuine yeah i
mean i i think it was genuine what i saw
and i'm pretty good judge of character
it was very genuine she's a really good
judge of character which is how she
ended up representing donald trump as of
course you can imagine and i've been one
to come out and say leticia james at all
her comments and no it was a very
humanizing uh
moment and i think it was important
especially given what our country looks
like right now to see that people on
opposing sides
can sit down and actually be real and
genuine and like each other right
really an inspirational moment in uh
bridging
our differences when donald trump and
the attorney general investigating him
were able to
kind of be cordial to each other really
really incredible here's mike pillow
advertising coffee on fox news that i'm
actually curious about let me see
oh it seems to be over okay we missed it
we missed the mike pillow commercial
thanks to ms frazzled for the twitch
prime subscription putting us at 127.
let me thank a few other people who are
signing up at joinpackman.com because
the the website is about to dump because
of the pressure it's under frederick
lyon is a new member
um barbara ritacco is number two ashley
lavallee number three tyrone moss number
four
josh newton is number five jason jones
number six
daniel limpke thank you for signing up
number seven emma rossiter is new member
number eight
john cho
is number nine belvedere the scounge is
number ten delightful shelton is number
11. walter mckenneth is number 12.
ember dean is number 13
james c number 14.
sophie bond davies is new member number
15.
uh guillermo ramirez or as we would say
in argentina guicheremo
is number 17. nikita mogolevski is
number 18 derek penkert number 19. jacob
holt is number 20.
eric brady is number 21. i think we're
going to do it guys raven reb is number
22. chris kurick number 23
paris mood is 24. denise knight is 25.
adam bailey 26 i can barely keep up with
these thanks to faye elder
donald probst
nicholas vetlichni
and demetrius wallace that's 30. so that
already puts us at 157.
let's see if we can go for 200
uh and that'll involve paul thomas
as well as brandon brewer
uh mark perkins and ron mcwilliams i
don't even know that i can actually keep
up with this the the memberships are
coming in faster than i can
even say let's see if i count them up
one two three four five
six seven
that's another seven 168.
and then the gifts are just dumping in
all right let's get back to that i i
quite i quite literally can't even keep
up with the numbers um let me get to a
few other super chats here
uh how much will this hurt the left if
nothing becomes of this
i believe it will indeed hurt the left
i believe it will be very bad for the
democratic party
if nothing comes of what has taken place
this week i'm right there with you
and that's
that's a serious consideration
um
david thank you for the hair care advice
it's already gotten me a date that's
great news rusty that's that's
absolutely fantastic news all right
let's get to a little bit of the andrew
yang interview as some of you know
andrew yang has started a third party it
is the forward party now i know andrew
yang we're friendly he's been on the
show a bunch of times i think he's a
perfectly nice guy
i've also said
i've also said
that i don't really get the forward
party i just don't really get it for me
i'm all about third parties but for me
the problem is the democratic party is
too centrist i want a viable third party
that's to the left of the democratic
party not the green party okay the green
party has has shown itself he listened
the green party has been filled with
people that just do absolutely nothing
for for me you know jill stein and the
the guy who was a running mate
in uh
2016 away just
the green party does nothing for me we
need
a serious
to the left of the democratic party
third party when andrew yang says let's
bridge
center-left democrats
and center-right republicans to make a
third party
that doesn't sound interesting to me and
he went on there are people who say that
jim acosta was rude to andre yang there
are others who say that jim acosta
exposed that this entire party doesn't
really make any sense
let's uh
let's listen to some of this on both
sides but you're gonna have to come up
with policies negative results
right yeah but andrew you're going to
have to have policy uh positions at some
point how does the forward party feel
about roe versus wage should have been
overturned
well i i personally uh think that
women's reproductive rights are
fundamental human rights right but see
this is the issue
his whole thing is
here's my view and i'm in the forward
party
but that doesn't mean it's our official
position
well so then but
does your
the whole point is what are the
positions of the party
i don't know i'm feeling a little bummed
out about this he's like i i believe in
reproductive okay you're right but so
okay what's the party's position the
forward party has uh not left or right
but forward stance on even the most
divisive and contentious issues oh god
that's he like that's not good guys
i would love to have andrew back on
you all know that when he's on
i just tell i just tell it like it is to
him i just see it i tell it like i see
it and one of the things i said to him
was like who's welcome in this thing or
white nationalist welcome he said yes
then he got into hot water so he had to
backtrack on what he told me
we're not left or right but we're
forward i i don't know guys i'm not sure
not left or right but forward stance on
even the most divisive and contentious
issues what is that don't you have to
take a position on something you don't
have to take a position on something
you can't just say well you know this is
a hot button issue so i'm not going to
take a position on you you know you want
to run the country you're going to have
to make some hard decisions andrew yeah
i don't guys i don't think acosta's
being rude at all
there are people who wrote to me and
said acosta's being incredibly rude to
him
he's asking someone who started a party
what are your party's positions
it's this is just fundamental
this is fundamental
again the forward parties about that
common sense consensus majority view
which is very clear on abortion it's
clear what about guns
but so
yes it's true
the majority view on abortion is it
should be legal in most cases but so why
is that not the position of the forward
party
right i mean maybe i'm missing something
here
climate change is actually clear on just
about every issue under the sun should
18 year olds be able to buy air
because of the nature of our system
should 18 year olds be able to buy
ar-15s
again the common sense consensus
majority is that there should be some uh
rules around background checks and
access to
oh god
the consensus is there should be some
rules about guns
oh this i'm oh man i i don't know guys
this uh you know that andrew's been on
the program longer than he was even on
the national stage but
i don't know if this is sounding like a
no for me dog
is kind of where i am
to firearms but we're not getting any of
these things jim because the two-party
system does not need to deliver it
doesn't sound like you're taking any
hard positions it sounds like you're
great power it sounds like you're you're
sort of a fill in the blank party you're
you know if if somebody uh wants a a
party with no clear policy positions
you're it but unfortunately in the real
world
in the real world you have to take a
position on something
well
where for the common sense consensus oh
daddy's saying
oh my god
is it am i am i wrong that this is
terrible
if i'm if i'm just off base here if i've
lost the plot
if this saying it please tell me
like
it's awful okay all right fair fair
i mean it just seems like this doesn't
make any sense
it's very bad messaging okay fair all
right well i'm glad i'm not going
overboard then
uh
what the hell are they showing here this
is a tucker what what is this let's see
what's on fox news this is an animal
it's a classic case you can see the
mandible is excised the tongue has gone
from deep within the uh all right let's
let's maybe get out there i don't know i
don't think that's for us
i don't know what the hell fox news is
running here
uh okay
it's a weird night it's a very very
weird night all right let's continue so
we looked at this andrew yang clip
um here's one more from the andrew yang
jim acosta interview product
presidential candidate andrew yang he
recently helped form a new political
party called forward alongside two
former republican officials we should
know ford also happens to be the title
of his recent book and andrew thanks
very much for joining us can i ask you
about something that you tweeted about
the fbi search
at mar-a-lago you wrote it looks
increasingly like the fbi raid was to
find mishandled classified documents and
not some other doj investigation which
was my first thought mishandling
documents doesn't seem like raid
material it does however seem like
excellent
campaign material for trump and i have
to ask you it sounds like you're you're
letting trump off the hook here uh
taking top-secret documents to your
mansion is okay with you uh are you
giving trump a pass
well thanks jim it was a very disturbing
report you just got from dhoni and the
fact is extremism is on the rise
throughout the country uh it's one what
does anybody know what this has to do
with the question
like i'm almost feeling like i'm in a
weird vortex
i
i want to hear that what what did that
have to do with the question trump off
the hook here uh taking top secret
documents to your mansion is okay with
you uh are you giving trump a pass
well thanks jim it was a very disturbing
report you just got from dhoni and the
fact is extremism is on the rise
throughout the country uh it's one
reason why we think the forward party is
so vital because we think there needs to
be
a broad positive okay he's talking about
the previous segment okay
defying third party movement but unfor
anything that enhances national security
and the rule of law uh and our hope is
that as the attorney general
uh and the doj
dig in that the american people get a
lot of the answers that many of us are
eagerly anticipating
but so what what is his opinion about
the trump thing that he was asked about
i don't even understand what's happening
here
are you saying that i don't think you
answered my question are you saying that
the uh
all right fine so acosta also doesn't
think the question was answered at least
we're on the same page there general had
political motivations
uh with this search i trust that that
all of the doj employees and
particularly the fbi agents are faithful
public servants discharging their their
duty uh and it it it hurts us all
that uh people are
singling out individuals in the way that
donate described it's truly awful
this interview is kind of a wreck it's
it's it's a mess
it's like a verbal ink blot
uh okay we looked at this already
um rudy giuliani i mentioned he has been
notified that he is indeed the target of
an investigation in georgia into
attempts to overturn the results he
appeared on what is this is this newsmax
and uh
okay here's what he had to say
it's just a further uh desecration of
the sixth amendment
i was his lawyer of record in that case
the statements that i made uh are either
attorney-client privileged because they
were between me and him or they were
being made on his behalf in order to
defend him
when you start uh when you start turning
around warriors into defendants when
they're defending their clients we're
starting to live in a fascist state look
i've already had my war office uh raided
i never thought i'd ever see that happen
it's just a further uh desecration of
the sixth amendment
i was his lawyer of record in that case
i don't know guys it's starting to seem
to me like rudy might not have a clue
what the hell is going on
i don't even know that i have much to
say about this it's just
rudy's in very serious trouble
i was sent this picture
of mike pillow
at a sarah palin fundraiser we're doing
a class action lawsuit against all
machines i don't know if this is some
kind of strange forced perspective image
but
pillow looks extraordinarily
short and rotund
while sarah palin looks strangely like
stretched out i i don't is this a
distorted picture does anybody know i
don't even know what we're looking at
here
it's a very very strange picture
anybody have any idea that's sarah palin
yeah people are surprised it seems like
one of those mirrors yeah
i i don't know
i don't know very weird
extraordinarily weird
uh foreshortening yeah i did the image
certainly seems foreshortened i'll tell
you that for absolutely certain
um okay we are moments away from the i
want to see what start with hannity's at
nine o'clock i think
i can't wait to see what happens on
hannity so we're gonna stand by for that
and in the meantime i i i'm not to be
able to say everyone's name because so
many people have been dumping in
memberships let me just count them up 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 17.
uh okay 17 plus 168 puts us at 185
and then there are 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
gifted subscriptions
which puts us at
195
and then over on twitch rover beef stews
virtual rogue and jacrissy signed up
which puts us at 199. whoever's number
200 on my website i'll send you a free
item from my from my store coffee mug
t-shirt whatever
okay let's look at some of the super
chats that have been coming in
let's apply this to life you go to a
restaurant you order and you ask is
there onion in the soup i'm allergic
they say many consider soup better
without onion i like onion
are you going back to that restaurant if
this is an analogy to the yang interview
then yeah it's quite accurate yang the
best time to start a third party is
during a fascist uprising right
andrew yang's position on the trump rate
is the common consensus position not
left or right but forward beautifully
set
we should only be using the title the
dishonorable former president donald
john trump
hold on do i have my uh
i don't even think do i have this
no i don't i was going to do my uh
donald trump clip imagine not being a
david pakman member says bronx bjorn
oh let's listen to what's going on
lying in misdeeds gender affirming care
that's a phrase you're seeing everywhere
including conservative media to their
great stream what is gender affirming
care well it's castrating children it's
exactly what it is and it's become
finally
trump's cfo is about to take a plea
rudy's a target of a criminal
investigation trump says he got his
passports seized and can't leave the
country look at what tucker is covering
just unearthed evidence of a drug
smuggling operation aimed at young
children lipstick tick tock found this
online post from someone called eli
ehrlich he says he's a phd student at uc
santa cruz libs of tick tock
can't get access message me ehrlich
wrote i have a network with years of
extra doses relic said he wants to send
these drugs to quote trans youth
now that's a crime of course but
needless to say the doj has refused to
investigate jason whitlock is the host
of fearless
trying to assess what's going on not
with so the doj
there is an effort to give drugs this i
have to say them but the department of
justice is not interested
by the way no libs of tick tock is a
known doxing right-wing account that
doxes people and it has to do with
diversity equity and inclusion
they're all four and and tucker i'm
gonna go really big picture here
but but and i've said this before but
all of this to me is just satanic the
targeting
of young people why don't we want to be
hyperbolic here but this is the work of
a devil with horns now we got someone
trying to sell them
uh puberty blockers or hormones that
will change their identity and and it
all goes back to this country was
founded by people
who believed our rights came from god
and when i look at the left and that
that should have no bearing on civil
government even if it's their personal
opinion she founded on biblical
principles they want to disrupt all of
that and what we're going through right
now tucker is a process called sifting
and it's in the bible one of the last
things jesus said to his disciples luke
chapter 22 verse 31 he tells peter he
calls him simon says the devil wants to
sift you the sifting process is
separating us it's all these different
identities that they've invented in our
lifetime
this is
certifiable insanity
you're a republican you're black you're
white you're gay you're lesbian you're
this you're that we're all being
separated and our founders saw us as all
coming from one creator and even for
non-believers that founding worked for
all of us but as we're being separated
like wheat
we're that's why there's so much
divisiveness in this country
jason look the only person who would say
that on tv and we're grateful that you
did good to see you tonight thank you
well that was a two-minute appearance
tucker asked one question and jason
talked and now they're already in a
break what a bizarre program like what i
don't even understand the formatting of
this program
what is happening
i don't even get what we just saw
truly bizarre
truly bizarre
mr scott says via super chat it's
titillating how the doj probably has a
rock solid case to have executed a
search warrant at the winter hate house
real talk biden will probably pardon
trump to heal the country uh
i i certainly hope that's not the case
okay here's the pillow ad check it out
my slippers are almost completely sold
out as a special thank you i am
launching my brand new all season
slippers slides and sandals for as low
as 29.98
this is a limited time offer so go to
mypillow.com or call the number on your
screen use your promo code and you'll
get all my new footwear for as low as
29.98 my all season slippers are made
with my exclusive four layer design that
you won't find in any other slipper
probably for good reason fabric so you
can wear them all year round and my new
slides and sandals are made with
patented impact gel making them ultra
comfortable and extremely durable i
guarantee they'll be the most
comfortable footwear you'll ever own so
go to mypiller.com or call the number on
your screen now to get your very own all
season slippers slides and sandals for
as low as 29.98 with your promo code
saturday night night live could use this
as their cold open
without modifying it in any way
like you could air it just as is
amazing by the way what makes slippers
all season like aren't you in your house
either way
anybody know what it means that they're
all seasoned slippers what does that
mean
i don't use slippers so i just wouldn't
know it's a genuine question
nobody knows
okay
yeah nobody knows
they're all terrain okay that's fair
that's good
all right tai asks david why do you
think the right always links fascism as
a left-wing belief it seems to be a very
common belief with conservatives it
doesn't make sense right yeah fascism is
uh traditionally right-wing
it's because they're idiots that's why
does mike have bathrobes to complete the
escaped mental patient look they do sell
bathrobes yeah they absolutely do
david sir i think my wife may be up in
the air yeah after those ads it
certainly wouldn't be surprising to me
that's for sure
do do i even dare listen to a couple of
voicemails as we await
hannity or maybe it's laura ingraham who
comes up next do i even do i even dare
check out a couple voicemails
or is it just
too dangerous based on everything that's
going on
check them out
uh all right let's see what i got here
uh oh here's an actually this voicemail
seems substantive and it's about andrew
andrew yang's forward party let's check
it out hey david uh jonathan from
indiana i've called a few times um
i was i'm thinking about the uh andrew
ying forward party yeah and
i've noticed that that kind of mindset
this
centrist at all costs mindset i guess is
the best way you can put it
um
it's actually really common i live in
indiana i live in a red state
uh surrounded by you know conservatives
reactionaries
um
and
even they
uh a lot of times it's the right wingers
that kind of spout that and oftentimes
uh
the whole thing is
is brought up when you know
trump does something wrong or just a
republican politician does some crazy
[ __ ]
it always comes back to well you know
both sides are just as bad
or
all right so enlightened centrism both
sides is um yeah i totally uh
i get that
let's see
what else we have
here
so i was like having an off day
and i was um kind of like talking about
how i thought we should go tour with
mexico
in front of the donald trump supporter
just because like
i don't know i'm just feeling like
really passive aggressive
and um he's like mexican and filipino or
something like that like uh
an ex-boyfriend of mine
but he was he like responded to what i
was saying like oh you know we should go
out sometime
you know to
like go out on the town and hook up or
something and have fun
and i was thinking to myself like he's
got the agenda behind the donald trump
supporters to like threaten mexico and
then the girls are just supposed to like
throw themselves before the boys
i would have never thought in that but
that must be like
you know trump supporter logic of like
you know somebody wants to blow up my
home then you go ahead and like throw
your sex in front of them like that all
right well that's uh a lot going on
there uh with whitney here is tucker
carlson throwing to the next show let's
see how hannity covers this will he do
another 11 minute insane monologue
lounges on the beach in kiowa and south
carolina we're now tracking multiple
breaking stories tonight including new
developments from the shooting death
potentially caused by alec baldwin we
have more hypocrisy on climate change
this time with private jet hollywood
hypocrite leonardo dicaprio where do you
hear what he did well these are really
crucial stories
where one teachers union would decide to
lay people off based on their race
regardless of their seniority we'll tell
you that story and later we'll show you
how one brave good samaritan took
matters into his own hands by chasing
down a violent robbery suspect but first
tonight tensions remain very high only
one week after the fbi's raid on the
45th president's home mar-a-lago now
this unprecedented search and seizure
has further eroded sadly many americans
trust in the fbi and the doj
and is now causing the outrage all
across the country make no mistake the
fbi has earned their shattered
reputation and tonight we're going to
break down very special under the under
the stewardship of the director selected
by trump republicans no longer trust
what should have been and should be and
can be and once was the premier law
enforcement agency in the entire world
let me be clear this is very important
criticizing and questioning the
atrocious behavior
of the upper echelon of the fbi
is not in any way shape manner or form a
call to violence just today fox news is
learning that former president trump
directed his team to reach out to the
department of justice the message donald
trump will do whatever he can to help
this is the message in which in which
trump was threatening to incite violence
now president trump is right on this
program we totally condemn all threats
against the fbi and every other member
of law enforcement if you watch this
show we are consistent no doubt there
are cops that are bad apples we saw that
in the george floyd case they commit
crimes they abuse their power and target
their political enemies those people
must all be held accountable in a court
of law
and that would also apply to bad apples
in the fbi now sadly that almost never
happens if donald trump or a trump
supporter is the target of the abuse for
example take a look at former fbi
official peter strzok think deeply about
this go back to august 8th 2016. strzx
girlfriend top fbi lawyer lisa page
absolutely this rant is like straight
out of trump's playbook trump's
personally obsessed with this story
lover her colleague quote trump's not
ever going to become president right
right struck response he's not
we'll
stop it he said that as uh he said all
of that is a top fbi official one that
worked directly for the top leadership i
mean he might have met like we as voters
i don't i don't know what that means
i want to believe that the path that you
threw out for consideration in andy
assumably andrew mccabe's imagine
talking about the peter strzok lisa page
thing with everything that's going on as
such an obvious way to run interference
here for donald trump i mean it just
doesn't it
only people who are exclusively
consuming fox news
could even remotely think that this is
newsworthy ensure that one candidate can
never win a free and fair election in
america by the way where's that january
6 committee looking into this issue now
of course the insurance policy was none
other than the russia
collusion hoax peter strzok became the
lead this is like a frenzy of conspiracy
theories three his bias was clear it was
obvious his mission was political and
yet struck he never ever faced legal
consequences it's why i often say we
don't have equal justice or equal
application of our laws in america any
longer that is a sad thing to say but
sadly it's true strzok ends up with a
book deal his anti-trump fbi girlfriend
got hired by msdnc strzok himself has
received numerous invitations to appear
all over cable news including this
morning he was on with liberal morning
joe our old friend take a look
it's not that the fbi is targeting any
one side or the other what you see is
the fbi going out on a day in day out
basis objectively investigating
allegations of law
the guy that said we'll stop it we'll
stop it the fbi will stop it uh and if
your plan doesn't work we've got an
insurance policy no way he's going to
win
do we know the context of we'll stop it
like is the reason to think that strzok
meant we the fbi rather than we voters
or we people who don't like trump
have ever been held accountable for
example peter strzok's boss andrew
mccabe also was very open about his
hatred for donald trump mckay belong
with jim comey we know he hates trump
and yates sally yates rod rosenstein
they all signed off on either the fisa
warrant or the three subsequent renewal
warrants in doing so all of them
lied on an application that at the top
of the application says verified that
they verified the information we now
know
none of it was true this is nuts i mean
trump's search warrant under
investigation for violating the
espionage act
rudy target of a criminal probe
trump's cfo taking a plea to plead
guilty
um
trump
sort of thinly veiled threats to incite
more violence
and the conversation is peter struck
was that woman hillary rodham clinton's
dirty russian misinformation dossier
that she paid for they were warned that
the dossier was filled with salacious
campaign op research including russian
disinformation and it was not to be
trusted they were they were warned by
even bruce ohr in august of 2016. of
course it eventually goes to hillary
anyway and they swore in a court of law
that it was verified because as mccabe
once admitted they didn't have that
dossier they weren't going to get that
fisa application approved and they were
desperate to spy on the trump campaign
at that particular time and the trump
transition team and later the trump this
is exactly how you i'm sure you all have
seen with me those interviews where they
peop journalists and sometimes you know
luke beasley will go to a trump rally
and we'll interview people and these
people spit out grammatically incoherent
words
and it's this sort of stuff
and it's not even really english this is
where they get it it's just it it's impo
i i'm aware of all the things that
hannity is talking about in some general
sense and i can't even follow the
connection that he's drawing between all
of this stuff this is how those
trumpists end up at rallies
repeating versions of that that make
even less sense
knowing then what you know now about all
the things that we've come to find
would you have still signed the warrant
application against carter page in
october january and april
no i would want a much more complete
understanding of what we were right
thank you very much
so they're all admitting that they set
they signed a document that has verified
the word verified at the top
was not verifiable not one person held
accountable for what is corruption and
an egregious abuse of power especially
not the patron saint of the fbi jim
comey himself okay yeah i just can't do
it anymore i mean this is this is
absolutely nuts all right guys we got
the main stories um uh trump passport
story will hopefully have verification
or uh corroboration by tomorrow um
rudy is a criminal target as hannity
goes on to talk more about hillary
clinton and trump's cfo is going to be
taking a plea uh we've got a whole new
show tomorrow uh i got to get to bed
new show
interviews all sorts of different things
we'll see everybody tomorrow thanks for
joining me for this extra stream thanks
to everybody who supported and we'll see
everybody back here tomorrow go watch
hannity if you can tolerate this quite
frankly i cannot